we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p let's take a
quick listen to a voicemail this is a
voicemail about hatred mail take a
listen hey David I just wanted to say I
think my favorite thing about hatred
mail is that the people who are writing
in are probably the most likely the
people who would say that you should be
required to learn English to be a part
of this country yeah you're doing this
you know yeah that's funny
so the patriot mail is is these dramatic
readings of hate mail that I get hatred
mail is known for horrible spelling and
grammar and politically it's the hatreds
who would insist that everybody must
learn English and speak English in the
United States and that other languages
aren't acceptable that is a an
interesting contrast with hatred mail
that never occurred to me before
voicemail caller didn't really finish
the point but I think we both picked up
on this yeah yeah yeah I understand what
they're saying for sure and it is a very
very good point about hatred mail and
unfortunately I wouldn't expect hatred
mail to become the the type of
incredibly well-crafted a narrative
prose that we might be used to if we
regularly read well-written fiction or
whatever we've got a great bonus show
coming up for you today we will talk
about ranked choice voting in Maine
under threat we will talk about why I
hop has changed its name and why it
might work and we will also talk about a
European dispute which leads to
Macedonia getting a new name join
pakman.com and patreon.com slash david
pakman show both ways to get instant
access to the bonus show